welcome everyone
to simply learns youtube channel java
was
ease and always will be the most sought
programming language
in the id industry yes you guessed it
right
the topic for today's discussion is the
java tutorial for beginners
so this particular part will be the part
1 of the tutorial
so without further ado let's dive into
the agenda
for today's discussion so we will begin
with a brief
introduction to java programming
language where we will go through a
little history of java
and the inventor who invented the java
programming language and
few more points followed by the
introduction to java
we will dive into the object-oriented
concepts in java
where we will learn encapsulation
abstraction
polymorphism and inheritance
so once we are done with the oriented
concepts in java
we will enter into the most crucial
concept in java that is the access
modifiers
where we will learn how java provides
access to its objects and classes
next after that we will learn methods in
java
followed by the methods we will go
through the most important part of
java the data structures or in other
words the java collections
and finally we will be winding up the
session by going through
the file handling techniques in java so
i think i made myself clear with the
agenda
now let's begin with the first topic so
the first topic is
the introduction to java
so what exactly is java is the first
point of discussion in
introduction to java so this will be
giving us the
definition of java programming language
so basically
java is a class-based object-oriented
high-level programming language
invented by james costling in the year
1995
so java programming language is used in
various fields
some of the basic examples where java is
used are the software development
followed by that java is used in desktop
and mobile development
and also the android os development
so followed by the brief history of java
its definition
and its implementation we will dive into
the next sub topic of the introduction
in java
which will include the features that the
java programming language provides
so the significant features that java
programming language has to offer are
the first one java is an object oriented
programming language
so everything you create in java is in
the form of an object
so basically the class is the blueprint
of each and every object
so once you design the class you can
implement the class and create any
number of
objects you require in your programming
language
so java is an object-oriented phenomenon
that makes it highly extensible
every component programmed in java is
treated as an
object so followed by the first feature
we will learn
the second feature so the second feature
has to say that
java is completely platform independent
so java follows write once and run
anywhere principle
so it uses jvm or the java virtual
machine
this makes it completely platform
independent
how yes i'm going to explain that
concept so what exactly happens in java
is java has a component called
java virtual machine so basically
whatever the program
you write that particular program will
be compiled
but in java things are a little
different
so once you write the code the compiler
will translate the code
from high level language into low level
language which is
the byte code so this particular byte
code will be sent
to the java virtual machine for
compilation so the java virtual machine
will compile the byte code instead of
the code itself
so this particular feature makes the
java virtual machine to perform in
any device regardless of the operating
system platform it is running on
so followed by the second feature we
will type into the third feature
so the third feature says that java is
completely simple
to learn the core reason to invent java
was to make the things simple to
understand read and
write so all the object oriented
programming concepts
and high readability make java the
simplest of
all followed by the third feature we
have the next feature
which has to say java is highly secure
java follows authentication based on
public key encryption
so this particular methodology makes
java highly secure
and this is used to design virus free
systems
so followed by the fourth feature we
have the fifth feature
the fifth feature says that java is
architecturally
neutral java runtime machine provides
ability of generating architecture
neutral objects that can run on
multiple processors so followed by the
sixth feature
we have the seventh feature which says
java is
highly portable java uses a compiler
written using
an cc and posix sub suit making it
portable and requires
absolutely no dependencies to implement
code in any architecture
so we have discussed about the jvm
architecture earlier
so this jvm makes java highly portable
and capable to run on any operating
system platform
so followed by that we have the next
feature that says java is a completely
robust programming language java
eliminates most of the number of errors
in compile time itself
this makes java robust against any
errors
so what the last feature of java has to
say about
java has multi-threaded performance java
is capable to execute code
simultaneously above multiple processors
at the same time
this is possible because of the java's
multi-threaded nature
so these were the important features of
java programming language
followed by that the next sub segment in
the introduction to java are
the data types in java so the data types
are the building blocks of any
programming language
so java supports the following data
types in itself
so the first building block in java that
is the data type supported by java
is the byte next we have short followed
by that we have int
right next to it we have long on the
other hand
we have care boolean double and finally
float
there are also few more advancements in
the data types in java which are
supported in the latest versions as well
so followed by the crucial data types
supported in java programming language
the next concept that we will be
discussing in introduction to java is
the operators in
java so the java programming language
has support for various operators in
real time
so some of the mainly used operators in
java are
edition operator subtraction operator
multiplication operator
division increment decrement and modulus
operators
so the examples for these operators are
specified in the last column
of this particular table also we will go
through a practical program for a better
way of understanding operators in java
so you can see that we have switched to
the practical mode
now we are on eclipse ide now let's
quickly create a java project
so i have specified simply learn java as
my project name
you can see on the left hand we have the
simply learn java
now we have the source folder let's
create a new package
now we have our package here let's
create a new class
so the new class has been successfully
created so
as you can see i have a program on my
screen so this particular program is
designed to perform
addition subtraction multiplication
division and modulus operations
respectively
and finally we have another last option
to exit the program
so basically we are going to use switch
cases for this particular operation so
the first case is for addition
second for subtraction followed by that
we have multiplication
next we have division next is mod and
finally exit
so this is the program flow now let's
quickly run this
as you can see the program got
successfully executed and the output
console is asking for an input
now let's enter the first number
now let's enter the second number
so now let's choose the operation to be
performed one for addition two for
subtraction
three for multiplication four for
division five modulus and six for exit
now let's choose one now we can see the
result as 15
now again the loop has started and it is
asking for an
input
let's given 15 as the first number
and 5 as the second number now we have
various options
let's select 2 for subtraction and there
you go we have the result
now with that practical program executed
we will continue with our next topic
so the next topic in our docket is
keywords used in
java so before diving deep into the
keywords in java
we will understand what exactly is a
keyword so keywords are
special words that has special meaning
and these particular keywords are
completely predefined
that means the architects of java
programming language have
previously declared keywords and defined
the functionality of those particular
keywords
now java has the following keywords in
its target
some of the mainly used keywords are
boolean
final switch while continue if
class new static default extends
and many more so for a quick briefing
you can take a screenshot of this
particular slide
now followed by the keywords in java we
should move ahead into the next topic
where we will discuss about the
conditional statements in
java so what exactly are conditional
statements
so conditional statements are specific
statements which will be executed
when the condition specified is true
unless the condition is true
the score segment where the conditional
block is placed
will not be executed so java provides us
with the following conditional
statements
which are the if if else and nested if
so first we will discuss if statement
so on the right side you can see the
flow diagram the flow diagram includes
the control
the control of the program will enter
the conditional statements
where the condition is processed in case
if the compiler finds the condition
is satisfied and the statement is true
then
the control will execute the statement
which is inside the conditional
statement
else the control flow will directly
consider the condition to be false and
will
jump into the next segment of code and
that particular statement will be
executed so now we have understood the
definition of
if loop now followed by f loop we will
continue with if
else loop so now on my screen you can
see
on the right side we have another flow
diagram which is completely similar to
the if loop
the only difference is we also have an
else statement here
basically the program control will enter
into the condition
so the condition will be checked if the
condition is true
then a particular code segment should be
executed if the condition is false then
another segment on the other hand
will be executed once after either of
the statements
are executed the control will enter into
the
next code segment of the code and that
particular
next statement will be executed and the
control will exit the loop
now for a better understanding of both
if and if else loops
we will execute a program now on my
screen you can see a code segment which
is based on
if and if else loops now here we will
try to take an input
if the number is greater than 0 then the
output should be
number is positive if anywhere we
provide a negative symbol
then the output should be number is
negative
now let's try to execute this program
so you can see the program got
successfully executed
and it is asking for an input now let's
enter a random number
which is 10.
so we have the output which says number
is positive
now that we have finished the execution
of that particular program based on
if and if else conditions we will move
ahead into the next type of conditional
statement
which is nested if else loop
so followed by if else we have the elsef
ladder or nested
if else loop so the control flow is
completely same
to that of the if else loop but the only
situation
that varies here is that we have
multiple else blocks
now here you can see multiple choices if
the choice is one
my particular food selection will be
noodles
if the choice is two it'll be milkshake
three for fruits four for coffee
and if i provide any other number other
than one two three and four
these statements should be invalid input
now let's try to execute this program
as you can see the program got
successfully executed and the console is
asking me for an input
now let's select three for fruits so
that's how it works
it's completely similar to switch
statement
having said that let us also execute a
program based on switch control
statement
so on my screen you can see a program
based on switch control statement
so we have months of a year so for case
one
we should be providing the output as
january similarly
next we'll have february march april and
finally we have december
if the number provided is any other
number other than the numbers between 1
to 12
then the switch control statement should
throw an output
which says invalid input now let's try
to quickly execute this program
so there you go we have our program
executed and we have our console asking
for an input
let's provide 12 so we have december now
our program is running successfully
now with this we shall continue with our
next topic the next topic
in the docket is loops in java
earlier we discussed the control
statements which were the if if else
if else ladder switch etc
now we will continue with the loops in
java which are the for loop
while loop and do while loop so the
first one we have is the for loop
on the right hand side you can see a
flow diagram
now the program will start at the
initialization state
once the initialization process is
finished the control will enter into the
condition
so the control will check the condition
in case if the condition is true
then the statement will be executed and
the control will flow
into the increment or decrement
statement and again the control flow
will enter into the condition for a
quick recap when you look at the for
loop
then we have i is equals to 0 i is less
than or equal to
a specific number then i increment or
decrement
so the first part where i is equals to 0
is the initialization
that's where you provide your i variable
or the counter variable
and initialization with a number which
can be 0 or any number you choose
sometimes you may choose zero or
sometimes you may even choose one
based on your requirement once the
initialization part is done
we have i is equals to or less than a
specific number
which is the condition so that's where
the control will check for the condition
in case if the condition is true then
the statement which is present inside
the for loop will be executed
once the statement is executed then the
last part which is i plus plus or i
minus minus which are your increment and
decrement operators
specifically so those particular
statements will be executed
in case if the condition is false then
the control will directly
exit the for loop and execute the next
statement which
are lying after the for loop so this is
how the for loop works
for a better understanding let's execute
a practical program
so on my screen you can see a simple
program based on for loop
so what we have is an initialization
variable i conditional statement that is
i
should be less than or equal to 10 and
finally
a pre-increment operation which is
plus plus i so what basically happens
here is it will print a print statement
that is
looped along with the i variable which
is 1 to 10
times that's all now let's try to
quickly run this program
so the counter variable that we provided
is 10
so it has looked for 1 to 10 times
now we should also consider another
example based on for loop
so now you can see another program on my
screen
so here what happens is you get to enter
a number
now once you have entered the number the
number will be evaluated
as even or odd and after that we will
print the sum of the even numbers until
the provided input and
followed by that the sum of the odd
numbers which are present in between
that particular segment
if you provide the number as 10 then the
sum of the even numbers between
1 to 10 will be printed and also the sum
of the
odd numbers between the number 1 to 10
will also be displayed
now let's quickly execute this program
and see the output
now we have the program successfully
executed and on the output console you
can see
the console is asking us for an input
now let's provide the number 10.
now there you go you can see the even
number summation from 1 to 10
is 30 and the sum of the odd numbers up
to 10
is 25 so followed by the normal for loop
we have another for loop
which is an advanced follow let's check
out an example to understand
advanced for loop in a better way so it
is also called
as enhanced for loop basically the
functionality of the enhanced for loop
or the advanced for loop is completely
similar to the normal follow
but the only difference is it reduces
the number of lines used in the code
segment
now let's try to execute this program
and see the output
so basically we had an array which store
the string values
which are the names of the fruits and
using the advanced for loop statement
here
we are going to access the elements
inside the array
and we are going to just print it so
that's what happened on the output
console here
we have access the array and inside the
array we had the names of the fruits
which are printed
directly over here now with that
we will enter into the next part of our
tutorial today
which is the while loop
so you can see on the right side we have
the control flow for the
while loop so basically the control of
the program
enters into the file condition first of
all and it will check the condition
in case if the condition is true then
the statement inside the while loop will
be executed
and the control will get back to while
condition
for evaluation in case if the control
finds out the condition is false then it
will
exit the while condition and execute the
next particular statement
now for a better understanding let's
execute a practical program
now you can see that we have a program
on my screen
so this particular program is really
simple all you get to do is enter
an input and that particular input
number will be evaluated as a prime
number
or not a prime number now let's quickly
execute this particular program
and there you go the program has been
successfully executed
and on the console it is asking for an
input now let's enter a prime number
which is
seven so you can see the program has
written us
that seven is a prime number now we will
enter into the next type of
loop in our tutorial which is the do
while loop
so the two while loop and while loop are
completely same to each other
there is no much of a difference the
only
major difference between the both is the
statement
in do while loop first the statement
will get executed
after the statement is executed then the
condition is checked
in while loop we had the condition first
so the only difference is
in do while loop the statement will be
executed
at least for once without checking the
condition
now to understand do while loop in a
better way let's try to execute a
practical program
so you can see that we have a simple
program to execute
the do while loop all we have is the
integer type variable i
which stores the value one and after
that
we have the do while loop segment so
inside the do while loop segment
we have a print statement so this
particular print statement will print
the value of i
and after that the i value will be
incremented
so this particular code segment will be
executed before checking the condition
which is while i is less than or equal
to 20.
once the statement is executed the
condition
is checked so let's try to execute this
program and see the output
so there you go the two while loop has
been successfully executed and the
numbers from 1 to 20 are been printed
successfully so this is how the do while
loop
works now with that we have finished our
introduction to java programming
language
and also some of the basic concepts in
java programming language
so now we will enter into the next stage
in java
that is the object oriented programming
concepts in java
so let's have a quick peek on the list
of concepts that we will be discussing
in java object oriented programming
concepts
so first we will understand what exactly
is a class and then the objects in java
followed by that we will have a briefing
about constructors in java
next we will start with the core
concepts of object oriented programming
which are the abstraction interface
encapsulation
inheritance and polymorphism now without
further ado
let's quickly get started with classes
and objects in java
so what exactly is a class let's
consider a small example
assume that you're going to build a
house so before you build a house
you will create a blueprint so with a
blueprint you can
create any number of similar kind of
houses
so similarly in case of java a class
acts as a blueprint so class here
describes the way
or behavior of a particular object of
its
type so followed by class now we will
enter into the next one which is the
object
so what exactly is an object as
discussed before in the normal example
the blueprint before building a house is
considered as a class
and the building what you construct
using the blueprint is called as an
object
similarly in java objects have states
and behaviors
and an object is an instance of a class
now we will go through the three basic
fundamental steps which are used to
create objects and classes in java
so the first step is the declaration
step you need to provide a name for your
variable with relevant data type
after that the second step is the
instantiation
the new keyword is used to create a new
object
remember whenever you try to create a
new object
using the class name you need to specify
the keyword called new and the last
stage is the initialization
after using the keyword a constructor is
called by the jvm to create the object
using the defined class so with that
we enter into our next concept that is
the constructors in java
so first we will understand what exactly
is a constructor in java
so a constructor can be defined as a
built-in method that is used to
initialize objects
using the class definition the
constructor is called
when the object of the class is created
so
the one and only major purpose of a
constructor is to
build objects using classes now followed
by the constructors
we have our next concept
now we will be discussing the
abstraction in java which is the first
object-oriented programming property in
java
so what exactly is abstraction in java
we will begin with the definition
so abstract class is a template of
methods and variables used in a program
abstract classes cannot be instantiated
directly
so to simplify the definition of
abstraction we can consider
abstraction as a process of hiding the
complex code implementation from the
user
so basically it is a method of providing
the user
with the basic necessities what exactly
the user is looking for
by keeping him away from the complex
implementations of the code
for example if you are using facebook
then you will be interested in
messages and new posts or something
similar to that
but you will not be worried about the
code implementation which has been under
facebook application
so that's the basic definition of
abstraction now that we know the basic
definition of an abstract class in java
and also know the procedure of
abstraction we shall now move ahead and
understand the features of abstract
classes in java
so there are mainly five features that
an abstract class in java has to offer
they are so the first feature is a
template
abstract classes basically offer a
template kind of structure
to all the applications and software's
designed using this particular
abstraction method so the next important
feature is
abstract classes provide loose coupling
so what exactly is loose coupling
loose coupling is a process where you
keep the lowest
possible dependency between a class and
an object
so followed by loose coupling we have
the next major feature
that is code reusability using abstract
classes there is a high chance of
reusing your code which saves time and
energy
the fourth feature is the process of
abstraction itself
this keeps the user from complex
implementations and
only provides with the required
information
and the last important feature is the
dynamic code resolution
so now that we know the features of an
abstract class we will continue with an
example for a better understanding of an
abstract class in java
so on my screen you can see a program so
this particular program is an example
for abstract classes in java
so to create an abstract class in java
we are going to use the abstract keyword
so here i have created a generalized
class which is a person
so this particular person will be having
a name and agenda
so this particular abstract class will
be implemented
by another class which is called as an
employee class
so this particular employer class will
be having the employee id
name of the employee and other details
so this particular employee will be
extending
the person class and it will be printing
the details of
a certain employee who is pavitrader
party
now let's try to execute this program
and see the output
so you can see that the program got
successfully executed
and the particular employee which is
pavitra party
and her gender is female is successfully
logged into the office
now with this let us continue with the
next topic that is the interface in java
so what exactly is an interface so an
interface can be defined as a container
that stores the signatures of methods to
be implemented in a code segment
to explain the interface in a much
detailed way an interface in java
programming language is an abstract
type that is used to specify a behavior
that
a class must implement they are similar
to protocols
interfaces are declared using the
interface keyword
and only contain method signature but
not the complete method
definition and constant declarations
now that we know the definition and a
briefing about interface now let's get
into the features offered by interface
in java
the first feature offered by interface
in java is the total abstraction
next is multiple inheritance so
multiple inheritance in java is not
possible because
it creates an ambiguity which is also
popularly
known as diamond problem so by using
interfaces
we can create an environment where we
can implement the multiple inheritance
the last but not the least loose
coupling now that we know the features
offered by an interface in java
let's move ahead and understand the
basic differences between an abstract
class and an interface
so the following table describes
differences between an interface and an
abstract class
so to declare an interface in java the
keyword we use is
interface and similarly on the other
hand the keyword used to declare an
abstract class is
abstract the next difference between the
both is
subclasses can implement an interface
whereas
in the abstract class the subclasses
extend the interface
so implement and extend are the two
keywords
so if you had to borrow the properties
of an interface into your class
then you need to specify it through the
keyword which is implement
and similarly in the abstract classes
you need to specify the keyword extents
so the third difference is multiple
interfaces can be implemented
so just assume that you have multiple
interfaces for example
three interfaces so if you wanted to
implement all the three interfaces into
one class
you can do that but on the other hand in
abstract class
only one abstract class can be extended
at
one particular stage and the final
difference between the both is
interface supports multiple inheritance
that is
it resolves the major issue related to
diamond problem
and on the other hand abstract classes
cannot support
multiple inheritance now to understand
interface in a much better way let's go
through a practical example
so right now on my screen you can see a
code segment
so this particular code segment is an
interface so here
the interface name is area so this
particular interface acts as a container
that stores the signatures of the
methods so the methods that we are going
to use
are square circle rectangle and triangle
so what does these methods do they
simply calculate the area of a square
area of a circle area of a rectangle and
area of a triangle respectively
so an interface just stores the
signature of these four methods
so the implementation of all these four
methods is inside this particular class
which is known as shape area so shape
area will be implementing the interface
area so inside this class we have the
code implementation
which is dedicated to calculate the area
of that particular shape
now let's quickly execute the program
and see the output
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and you can see
the output displayed on my
console right now it's asking for an
input that is the radius for the circle
let's provide the radius
so the radius provided was 15 and the
area of circle
with radius 15 is 706
so similarly now it's asking for the
length of the side of a square
so we all know that the area of a square
is side into side so 25 into 25 is 625
now it's asking for the length of a
rectangle
so similarly let's also provide the
breadth of the rectangle
so the area of a rectangle is l into b
which is
600 now next we have the triangle
now it's asking to input the base of the
triangle
next we have the height of the triangle
so the area of the triangle with base 35
and height
45 is 787 now with this let's enter into
the next
object oriented programming concept that
is the encapsulation
so what exactly is encapsulation so
encapsulation in java
can be defined as a process of
encapsulating or bundling the data
and methods that operate on that
particular
data so in simple terms you're trying to
combine
the data members in a class or an object
along with the data manipulating methods
of the class or an object
now to understand encapsulation in a
much better way
let's try to execute a small program so
on my screen you can see a program
so in this particular program the class
name is encapsulation
so inside this class we have the name id
and h of
a person so in the next segment of code
we have another class called run
and here we are trying to encapsulate
the methods set name
set age and id number of a specific
candidate
whose name is harry age is 25 and id
number is
829468 now let's try to execute this
particular code segment
and see the output
as you can see the code has got
successfully executed and output is
being displayed on the
output console now with this
we will enter into our next concept that
is
inheritance so what
exactly is inheritance inheritance is an
act through which a new class gets
created by acquiring
the variables and methods which are
defined in the previous or
the parent class
for an example consider an older model
of
a cell phone so an older model of a cell
phone had
two major functions which is call
function
and sms function now imagine that you
wanted to create
a new smartphone which has some
additional functions
apart from call and sms which might be
media and internet browsing now let's
come back to both the phones
imagine that you have started to work
with the creation of
a new smartphone so you had to define
media
call sms and browse methods but
remember in the older phone we already
have the
methods which are called an sms so
will you create the call and sms methods
again or
will you use the code which is already
defined for you
so the smart move would be using the
previously defined methods into your new
phone
and only work on the two new methods
which is
social media method and internet
browsing method so this particular
approach or this particular process is
called as inheritance
so basically what you're doing is you're
trying to inherit
the previously defined methods that are
call and sms methods into your
new smartphone and adding the only
necessary code for your smartphone
which will be the social media methods
and internet browsing methods
so this is how inheritance practically
works
now there are four different types of
inheritances available in
java so the first one is single
inheritance
in single inheritance we have two
classes
so here the class a is called as the
base class
or also a parent class so the class
which is inheriting the properties of a
parent class or a base class
is called as the child class so in here
the b class is known as the child class
now
the next type of inheritance is the
multi-level inheritance
so it is completely similar to single
inheritance
but the only difference is we have
another child that is c
and here the one major point that you
need to keep in your mind is
the class b is also a child
as well as a parent so class b is a
child to the parent class a
and class b also acts as a parent for
the child class c
so here child flash c is inheriting the
properties from
the base class a as well as its base
class b
so followed by multi-level inheritance
we have the third type of inheritance
which is the irrql inheritance so
hierarchical inheritance has multiple
child classes
so a is the parent class or base class
and the properties of
a are been distributed amongst the child
classes which is b
c and d and finally we have the last
type of inheritance
which is the hybrid inheritance the
hybrid inheritance name is
self-explanatory
it is a combination of all the three
inheritances
so here you can see the inheritance
between
a and bc classes is
hierarchial inheritance and the
inheritance between
c d classes is single level inheritance
and the inheritance between classes a
c and d is multi-level inheritance
so to sum up we can say the hybrid
inheritance is a combination of
any of the three inheritances don't
worry
we will discuss each and every type of
inheritance
in a much more detailed way along with a
practical example
so the first one that is the single
inheritance
single inheritance consists of one
parent class and one child class
here child class inherits parent class
methods and data members
so to understand single inheritance in a
much better way let's try to execute a
practical program
so on my screen you can see an example
based on inheritance
so here we have two different classes
that is student class
and bob class student class is the
parent class
and bob is the child class so what we
are going to do here is we are going to
extend the properties of parent class
that is student class
into the child class bob now let's try
to execute the program and see the
output
so you can see that the program was
successfully executed and we have
extended
the properties of student class into the
child class
bob now with this
let's move into the next type of
inheritance that is the multi-level
inheritance
so multi-level inheritance is also a
parent-child inheritance relation
but the difference is the child class is
inherited by another
child class now let us consider an
example based on
sports bikes so we have a program based
on multi-level inheritance on my screen
so bike is the base class and followed
by that
ninja which is the name of the bike is a
child class and followed by
ninja we have ninja 1000 r which is
one of the models of the name ninja
so this is the last child class and
ninja is
a child class which also acts as a
parent class
for ninja 1000r
now let's try to execute this program
and see the output
so the basic functionality of this
particular program is to
categorize the bike so the category of
the bike comes under 1000 cc segment
and the make of the bike is the ninja
and the model of the ninja is 1000 rr
the type of bike is sports manufacturer
is kawasaki and the maximum speed is 280
kilometers per hour
now with this let's move into the next
type of inheritance
that is the irrkel inheritance
so the hierarchial inheritance is a
parent-child relationship
the only difference is the multiple
child classes
inherit one single parent class
now let's consider an example based on
temporary employee and a permanent
employee
so on my screen we have an example based
on hierarchical inheritance
so in this particular example we will be
considering two different types of
employees
the first one is the permanent employee
and the second one is
the temporary employee so both these
employees
will have to access one single parent
class that is the employee class
now let's try to execute this program
and see the output
so after executing the program we have
the output on the
output console so basically both the
employees will access the same parent
class which is
the employee class which has the same
number of leaves
provided to both permanent employee and
temporary employee
but there is a variation in the number
of hours working
for a permanent employee the total
number of hours working
are eight and for a temporary employee
the total number of
working hours are 10.5
now with this let's move into the next
type of inheritance that is the hybrid
inheritance
as discussed before the name is
self-explanatory
hybrid inheritance is a combination of
any of the three types of inheritances
supported in java
now let us try to consider an example
based on hybrid inheritance
which will have the combination of
single level inheritance
multi-level inheritance as well as
hierarchical inheritance
so here we have the parent class that is
c as a parent class
and a which is acting as the child class
that is extending c
b will be extending c again and d will
be extending
a so as for the pattern here
we have b extending a and c extending a
and similarly d will be extending c
and a now let's try to execute the
program and see the output
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and the program
has printed the output
which will explain the type of
relationship of each and every class
with the other class so c is the parent
class to all a
b and d a has single inheritance with c
and shares hierarchy with b b has single
inheritance with c
and shares hierarchy with a and finally
d has single inheritance with a
and multiple level inheritance
with c now let's continue with the next
type of inheritance which is
basically not possible in java that is
the multiple inheritance
in other words it's also called as a
diamond problem
in java we do not have the support for
multiple inheritance as
it ends up as a serious ambiguity to
resolve this issue we have
interfaces now the next topic
is the has a relationship and is a
relationship
when a class inherits methods and
members from a different class then the
relation is said to be an
is a relationship for example orange is
a fruit
similarly t has a relationship when a
class inherits the
instance from a different class or an
instance
of its own class then it is said to have
a has a relationship for example orange
has
citrus taste now let's try to execute
programs based on ease a relationship
and
has a relationship for a better
understanding
so as you can see on my screen we have a
program based on
is a relationship so we have the first
class which is the customer
and the second class which is a bank so
a customer is related to bank
a customer is a customer with a specific
bank
so what exactly we are trying to do here
is we are trying to
access the methods and data members
from one class to another class
so we are basically accessing the
methods of customer class
through bank class now let's try to
execute this particular program and see
the output
so as you can see the program got
successfully executed
and we have the information of the
customers related to the bank
so we have five different customers
which are raju shiva
sachin prashant and john along with that
we also have their cities
now with this let us also try to execute
an example
based on has a relationship
so as you can see on my screen we have
an example based on
has a relationship so we have the first
class that is
the school which happens to be the
parent class and student happens to be
the child class
so here we are trying to access the
instance of the parent class
instead of the data members and the data
manipulation methods
we are trying to use the instance so
this makes this
to have a has a relationship with
another class
now let's try to execute this particular
program and see the output
as you can see the program got
successfully executed and we have the
output which says
toby marshall is the next student of st
john's school
now with that we have finished the
inheritance in java the last topic for
object-oriented programming is the
polymorphism in java
so what exactly we are going to discuss
in polymorphism in java
so the first one will be the types of
polymorphism available in java which are
the
runtime polymorphism and compile time
polymorphism
and next we have the super keyword and
finally
we are going to compare the differences
between runtime polymorphism and compile
time polymorphism
so first let's start with the definition
so what exactly is polymorphism
so polymorphism is the ability of an
object in a class to perform
a task in multiple methods which is
known as
polymorphism in java
so polymorphism is basically divided
into two categories
the first one is the runtime
polymorphism and the second one
is the compile time polymorphism so what
is
runtime polymorphism runtime
polymorphism is handled during the
program execution stage
here the overriding method gets resolved
in the execution stage
to understand runtime polymorphism in a
much better way we need to execute a
program based on
method overloading so this particular
code segment on my screen is an example
for
method overloading so what exactly is
method overloading
so method overloading is a process of
having
multiple methods in a program based on
the same name
so you can see that i have a method with
name
add here as well as another add method
here and another method here
so what's the difference between all
these three methods
so the first one is having integer type
data variables or data members
the second one has double type of data
members
and the number of data members here are
different
which is four and the last one has
two data members but the data type is
different
which is double so when you pass the
parameters of
integer data type with two data members
then the first add method will be
overloaded
when you send four different data
members
of double data type then the second
method will be overloaded
if you send two data members of double
type
then the third method will be overloaded
so this is how the program works
now let's try to quickly run this
program and see the output
as you can see the program got
successfully executed and the outputs
have been displayed here
now with this let's move into the next
topic that is
the compile time polymorphism so what
exactly is compile time polymorphism
compile time polymorphism is executed
during the compilation stage
here the overloading method gets
resolved in the compilation stage
whereas in the runtime polymorphism the
overloading method gets resolved during
the run stage
now to understand compile compile-time
polymorphism in a much better way
let's try to execute an example based on
method overriding
so this particular example on my screen
is based on method overriding
so both the civilian pilot and the cargo
pilot
will have to take off so the output will
be based on the method which gets
overrided during the compile time
as you can see i have stopped the
civilian pilot over here using the
course
now during the compilation stage the
jvm finds that there is clearance for
cargo pilot so this method will be
resolved during the compilation stage
and the output will be
cargo pilot ready to take off now let's
try to execute this code
there you go the program got
successfully executed and this is the
cargo pilot ready to take off
so this is how method overriding works
in real time
now let's move into the next topic where
we will discuss the differences between
runtime polymorphism and compile-time
polymorphism
so the first difference between the both
is in compile-time polymorphism
method call is handled by the compiler
during compilation stage
while on the other hand method call
cannot be handled by the compiler in
execution stage
in the runtime polymorphism the second
difference is
compile-time polymorphism is less
flexible and it needs to handle all
methods
in compile time whereas on the other
hand runtime polymorphism exhibits
higher flexibility as the method calls
get handled at
runtime the execution period for
compile-time polymorphism is less
whereas on the other hand
the execution period for runtime
polymorphism is really high
integrating the right method call with
the right method is done during the
compilation
time on the other hand integration of
the right method
call with the right method is done
during the run time
the last difference between the both is
the compile time polymorphism occurs
during
method overloading and operator
overloading whereas on the other hand
the runtime polymorphism is occurred
only during the method overriding
now we will understand what is super
keyword
so super is a predefined keyword in java
that is used to refer the
immediate parent class object or method
defined in the program
so to understand super keyword in a much
better way let's try to execute a sample
program
so on my screen you can see a code
segment so in this particular code
segment we are using the super keyword
to access the object or the data member
sites
which is present in the immediate parent
class now let's try to execute this
particular program and see the output
so there you go the program was
successfully executed and the output has
been displayed on the
output console so this is how the super
keyword works
it tries to refer to the objects of the
immediate parent class
now with this let's continue with the
next topic that is the access modifiers
in java so the next topic
is access modifiers so what exactly are
access modifiers
so here goes the definition access
modifiers in java
specify the accessibility of a variable
or a method
by a same or different class or
different method
so java has four different access
modifiers
so basically what an access modifier
does is it provides the
accessibility so every data member every
data manipulating method
object class will have their own
personalized accessibility through
access modifiers so we will understand
more about access modifiers and the
different types
through the following so first one we
have is the default access modifier
so what's the importance of default
access modifier and what does it do
so the accessibility of default access
modifier
will have the permit ability within the
package so when you provide a data
member or a data manipulating method
class
object without any specific access
modifier such as public private or
protected
so then the jvm will provide that
particular object class or
data manipulating method or data member
with default access modifier
so objects with default access modifier
are accessible
from anywhere throughout the package now
followed by the default access modifier
we have the next
one which is the public access modifier
so the public access modifier and the
default access modifier provide the same
level of accessibility
the only difference is in public access
modifier you specifically
provide the keyword public whereas in
the default access modifier
we don't have any specific keyword for
that
so the example is right here public
end add index into y so here we have the
integer type method add
so we are providing that with the access
modifier public and inside that we have
the parameters
now to understand this in a much better
way let's quickly try to execute a
program so on my screen you can see an
example
for public access modifier so when you
see on the left side
we have two different packages so the
first package being
java simply learn and the second package
is simply learn
java so i've jumbled the words just to
make it different
so now we have a program in
java simply loan which is the child
program
so inside this particular program we
have
a statement which says
system.out.println and
inside that particular statement we have
a method call that is a dot add
100 200. so we are sending parameters
and you can see we
don't have the addition function
anywhere inside this particular
code segment so that particular add
function or add method is provided in
the different package
that is simply learn java and inside
that we have the submission
dot java program so you can see that we
have the add method written inside here
so through child class we are going to
access
this particular method
now let's try to run this program and
see the output
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and the submission
of both numbers 100 and 200 is 300
which is printed on the output console
so this is how the accessibility of
the add method is open through public
access modifier
now let's continue with the next type of
access modifier which happens to be
the private access modifier the
accessibility of a private variable or a
private method
is completely limited to a specific
class
and that particular class or a variable
or a method
cannot be accessed anywhere outside the
class
so for example we have a small code line
here which is
private in value is equals to five so we
are using the keyword private
and we are declaring a value of integer
type and we are storing an integer value
5 inside that
now for a better understanding let's try
to execute a small
program now you can see that i have a
program on my screen right now which is
a small and really simple program
we have getter and setup methods here
along with the integer type variable
which we have declared as private
now we are going to access that
particular variable x is equal to 5
through our main class here now let's
try to quickly execute this program and
see the output
so there you go the program was
successfully executed and we have
accessed the value of
private variable integer x through
getter and setter methods
from our main method and we have also
printed
the message that is hello world
here is the function call for that
particular message so with this let's
continue with the next type of access
modifier which is a protected access
modifier
so the accessibility of a protected
variable or a protected method
is limited to a particular package so we
have discussed this package thing in the
first
type of access modifier which is the
public access modifier
so imagine that you have declared some
method or variable inside
the first package which was the java
simply learn and if you wanted to access
that particular
protected variable or method from the
different package
that is simply learn java then it will
not be possible
now let's try to understand this through
an example
so we have the first normal line of
example over here which says protected
void
print method so here the print method is
being protected
through the protected access modify a
keyword
now to understand this in a much more
detailed way
let's try to execute a small program so
you can see that we have a
program on my screen right now so we
have two different classes which is the
parent class and the child class so the
parent class is declared inside the
package simply learn
java and the child class is declared in
the package java simply learn
and inside the parent class we have a
method
which is protected and that particular
method is just a print method inside
that we have
a printf statement which is hello world
so inside the chat class we are going to
call that particular protected method
that is print so we are using the
command
import everything from simply learn java
package
now if we execute this particular
program we shall print that particular
message which is hello world
so there you go the program was
successfully executed and
the printf statement has been printed
here now with this let's continue with
our next topic
that is the methods in java
so methods methods are also known as
functions in other programming languages
such as
c and c plus plus so basically methods
are code segments that are called for
any number of times
and that can execute a task by just
passing
values so we are quite familiar with
methods there is no rocket science in
this
we have already executed many examples
based on methods
now followed by the methods we have the
next crucial concept in java tutorial
that has
the collections in java so the first one
is the array
so java collections are also known as
data structures in
other simplified terms so the first
java collection that we are going to
study about is the array
so array in java is a resizable array
that is an implementation of
list interface that allows null elements
as well
now we have three different types of
arrays normally
so the first one is the one dimensional
array so you can see on my screen we
have an example for one dimensional
array
so basically in one dimensional array we
just have one single row
and the elements in the row can be
accessed through the index
numbers now to understand this in a much
better way let's try to execute a small
code
so on my screen you can see an example
for one dimensional
array so we have one row for this
so the row has zero one two indexes and
we are going to store 10 20 30 inside
our array
and we are going to print it now let's
try to execute this program and see the
output
so there you go the program was
successfully executed
so we have printed the message one
dimensional array and the elements 10 20
30.
now let's continue with the next type of
array that is the two dimensional array
so you can see that there is much
difference between
one dimensional array and two
dimensional array so basically we saw
that we had
one row in one dimensional array but
here we have
two different rows it's possible that we
can also have
more than two rows in two dimensional
array so it's basically a matrix which
can be represented with rows and columns
so if you wanted to access any element
in this particular two dimensional array
then you have to specify the row index
and the column index as
a pair now to understand this in a much
better way let's go through a sample
program
so you can see an example on my screen
right now which is really simple
which has just two rows and two columns
and it's a two cross two matrix and the
elements which we are going to store are
one two three and four
now we are going to use two for loops
one for the row one for the columns
and then we are going to print the
elements in the two-dimensional array
let's try to quickly run this program
so there you go we have successfully
executed the program and the output of
one two three and four along with their
addresses
has been printed on the console here so
now we have the third type of
array which is a three dimensional array
by looking at the image you can make out
that
three-dimensional array is basically the
combination of multiple two-dimensional
arrays
so here the elements are stored in a 3d
rubix format and you can access the
elements in a three-dimensional array by
passing three vectors at the same time
so with this let's continue with the
next topic that is
this stack so what exactly is a stack
so stack can be defined as a subclass of
vector
that implements last in first out stack
defines the default constructor
which creates an empty stack now let's
understand more about stack
so you can see on my screen we have an
image of a stack
so stack is basically an arrangement of
elements
which follows first and first out so
just imagine that this is a container
so when you pass an element to the stack
then the first element will be located
at the location zero
followed by that we have the first and
second elements so
first element to enter the stack was at
stack number
zero so this element which came in first
into the stack
is the last one to leave the stack or in
the other way round
stack also follows this principle which
says last in first out
so the element at stack 2 was the last
element to enter the stack
so basically it will be the first
element when the stack starts to get
empty
so this is how stacks work to understand
in a much more detailed way let's try to
execute a program
so there you go you can see a program on
my screen which is based on stack
functionality so first we are going to
push the elements into the stack
then we are going to pop the elements
using the peak function we are going to
check out some elements which is on top
and which is on the last
and also we can find if an element is
present in the stack or not
so we have the functions over here which
is stack push
pop peak search so we are going to pass
some elements such as element 5 element
10 for searching this stack now let's
quickly execute this program and see the
output
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and we have the
following output
and remember that we have passed two
different values to search in this stack
that is 5 and 10
so the elements 5 and 10 are not present
in the stack
so it has returned the message saying
element not found
so as you can see we have pushed the
elements using the for loop
so the elements from 0 to 4 will be
pushed into the array
because we have provided the condition i
should be
less than 5 but not equal to 5. so the
element 5
was not pushed into the stack so when we
have given the element
5 it did not find the element 5 or
neither
10 but if we give the elements such as 2
or something
then i think we can find it let's try to
execute the program once again
so you can see that the element is found
at position number 3.
so that's how it works now with this
let's continue with the next type of
data structure or the java collection
which is the linked list
so what exactly is a linked list so
linked list class can be defined as an
implementation of
a list and dq interfaces this allows
null elements as well now we have three
different types of linked lists in java
which are singly linked list
doubly linked list and circular linked
list so you can see we have the first
image which describes the
functionality of singly linked list so
this part is called as the head which is
the
starting part of the linked list and
this part is called as the tail
which is the ending part of the linked
list so in between the head
and tail we have nodes so these nodes
are the combination of the element
value and the address of the next node
so the head will be pointing to the
first node which will have the first
element along with the address of the
next node
so this address block will point to the
next node in the linked list
similarly the second element and the
address of the third node
so this is how the linked list works and
at the end of the last
node instead of address value we store a
null value which indicates the
end of the linked list so this is how
the singly linked list works
now for a better understanding let's try
to execute a program
so on my screen you can see an example
for singly linked list
so here we have defined the node which
has the next value and the data
and inside the display function we are
going to display the node head and
the other data elements which are
present in between the head node and
tail node
and here we have described the head
second third and fourth nodes
respectively and here we are going to
display the list
let's try to execute this program and
see the output so there you go
the program got successfully executed
and we have inserted the nodes as one
two three four
and one is the head and fourth being the
tail
so the list has been successfully
printed here now with this
let's continue with the next type of
linked list that is the doubly linked
list
so by looking at the image you can make
out that we can
traverse doubly linked list in two
directions in the earlier linked list
we had one directional travel that is
from one
two and three and done but in doubly
linked list
you can travel in two ways that is one
two three
three two one so that's how doubly
linked list works that's the only
difference between single english and
doubly linked list
so in the head part you store the
element value
and starting address will be null which
indicates the
first element of first node and in this
next
address block we have the address of the
second node
and in the second node we have two
address blocks
so the first address block will point to
the previous node
and the second address block will point
to the next node
so in the tail part also we have two
addresses so the first address will be
pointing to the second that is the
previous element
and the last address will store null
which indicates the
end of the doubly linked list so for a
better understanding let's try to
execute a program real quick
now you can see on my screen there is a
program based on doubly linked list
so similar to the previous example we
are going to define the node first
then we are going to insert the elements
into the doubly linked list which are
one two three four
and five then we'll display the list
so let's try to quickly execute this
program
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and the notes of
the doubly linked list are one two three
four
and five now let's continue with the
last type of linked list that is a
circular linked list
by just looking at the image you can
make out that circley linked list is
basically a singly linked list
the only difference is at the end point
instead of a null value
we have head value so this head value
will
make the linked list to point out to the
first element
so this makes it as a circular
traversing linked list
so the name circular linked list so to
understand circular linked list in a
much more better way
let's try to quickly execute a sample
program
so you can see that we have a program on
my screen which is based on circular
linked list
so similar to singly linked list we have
the program here but we are making a
little change here
which is pointing the tail next to head
so that's the only difference that we
have made in this program
now we are adding the elements which are
from one to eight
and at last we are going to display the
circular linked list so let's try to
quickly execute this program
so there you see the program got
successfully executed and the elements
in the circular linked list are also
printed here
so with this let's continue with the
next type of data structure or
java collection that is
the queue
so what exactly is a queue so q
interface is from java.util
package it implements collection
interface the queue implements
first and first out remember stack used
to follow first
in last out but q follows opposite to it
that is
first in first out so by looking at this
image you can make out that when an
element enters into a queue it locates
at the queue location 0. so this
particular element at q location 0
will be the first element to leave the
queue when you start to empty the queue
so to understand cues in a much more
better way let's try to quickly execute
a program
so you can see that we have a program on
my screen based on the queue terminology
so we are basically going to add the
elements 4 5
3 6 8 into the queue and you can also
see that we have imported the libraries
of linked list
and queue together over here and now we
are also trying to remove some elements
from the queue and we are going to check
for some elements in the queue and also
we are going to
check out the size of the queue now
let's try to
execute this program and see the output
so there you go the program got
successfully executed
so as for the first operation the
elements 4
5 3 6 8 have been successfully added
into the queue
so after that we are going to remove an
element
which is 4 so we have deleted that
particular element
now again we have the queue which is the
updated queue
5 3 6 8 and the head of the queue is
now 5 the size of the queue is 4.
so this is how the queues work now with
this let's continue with the next type
of java collection
so that is hash set
so what is a hash set so it is basically
a hash set interface combined with hash
map
it allows null elements as well now to
understand hash
set interface in a much better way let's
try to execute a program
so on my screen you can see that we have
an example based on hash
set interface we have imported the
java.util.hash
set interface library and inside this
hash
set we're going to add elements which
are the names of the
bike makers and we have also tried to
include some duplicate values over here
you can see yamaha has been included two
times and also we are trying to add null
elements as well
now let's quickly try to execute this
program and see the output
so there you go so hash sets does not
allow duplication of elements but they
do allow null elements in the
set so that's how the hash set interface
works
now let's continue with the next type of
data structure or the java collection
that is the tree set
so the tree set is a navigable set
implementation based on tree map
here the elements are ordered using
comparators so you can see a program on
my screen right now which is an example
for preset
so we have imported the
java.util.trayset library into the
program
so inside the main program we are going
to insert some elements into the three
set
and then we are going to print the tree
set so lets try to run the program
quickly
so there you go the program got
successfully executed
but there is a change in the order of
printing you can see
the elements are already sorted from 0
to 8476 which is an ascending order
so sets basically arrange the order of
elements
by itself that happens implicitly so
followed by reset another
java collection that we are going to
discuss is the hashmap
so hashmap table is based on map
interface it provides
map operations and allows null values as
well
so to understand hash maps in a much
better way let's try to execute a
program
so on my screen you can see an example
based on hash maps
so here we are putting the elements in
the form of bikes
so honda is the manufacturer and cbr is
the bike name
similarly kawasaki to kathy and yamaha
now let's try to execute this program
and see the way
the hashmap prints the data
so you can see that we have the elements
here ducati pinagali and
yamaha r1 so basically maps follow the
pattern of
key value pairs so you can see we have
declared the hash map in the form of key
value pass
so the key is a string type data and
also the value is a string type data
so here the key is honda and the value
is
cbr which is the bike which is
manufactured by honda
similarly kawasaki ninja ducati pinagale
and r1 for yamaha so you can also see
that the same has been printed also
in the output console so this is how
hash maps work
so with this let's continue with the
next type of java collection
so that is the tree map so what exactly
is a tree map
so tree map is based on navigable map it
is sorted according to the natural
ordering of its keys depending on the
constructor being used
so to understand pre-map class in a much
better way let's try to execute the
program real quickly
so you can see we have a program on my
screen which is based on
tree map class so we have included the
libraries java.util.map.entry
and we've also used the star symbol in
the first place
in case if we missed out anything this
should include everything else
so inside the main method you can see
that we have four different key value
pairs
so the first type is integer and the
second type is the string
so the first integer type could be the
employee number or the id number of
the particular candidate and the name of
the candidate is the string type
now let's try to execute this program
and see the output so you can see the
program got successfully executed
and the key value presser has been
printed on the output console
so with this let's continue with the
next topic in our tutorial that is the
file handling techniques
so file handling techniques can be
defined as a procedure to manipulate
data
via the file system it includes create
get
read and write operations so we shall
execute a program
for each of the file handling techniques
starting from create
to write operations so the first one
will be to create
a file so on my screen you can see an
example based on file creation method
so we are going to create a file by name
java simply learn.txt
if the file already exists it should
give us a exception which says
file already exists if not it should
create a file now let's create the file
so when you run the program it should
successfully create the file yes
so it's thrown the message that is the
file is
successfully created so after the first
file manipulation operation that is to
create a file the next one is to
write into a file now you can see a
program on my screen which is based on
writing
operation onto the file so the file that
we are going to write on
will be javasimplylearn.txt now let's
get back to the documents where the
program has created the java simply
learn file
so there you go when you navigate
through my documents
and java eclipse workspace and inside
that we have simply learned java package
and inside that we have the file
java simply learn so basically this is
empty now is just created right now
now we are going to execute a write
operation
now we will be writing the following
text into that file which is
files in java might be tricky but it's
fun enough
now let's try to execute this program
and see the output
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and we have also
included a print statement in this
program
so even we have printed this particular
text that is hello welcome to simply
learn
now let's get back to our file system
and see if the data has been written
into the file or not so there you go
inside the java simply learn
we have got the text return which is
files in java might be tricky
but it's fun enough now the last file
manipulation operation will be to read
the file
now let's execute a program based on
that operation and see the output
so on my screen you can see that we have
a program based on
reading function so we are going to read
the data which is present
in java javasimplylearn.txt now let's
try to quickly execute this program and
see the output
so there you go we have the output
successfully executed and the
statement which is present in the
simplylearn or javasimplylearn.txt file
was the same which is files in java
might be tricky
but it is fun enough so with this we
have come to an end of this particular
java tutorial for beginners part one so
if you had any queries regarding this
tutorial or if you require the code that
we have executed in this particular
tutorial
then please feel free to write us down
in the comment section below
and we will respond to you at the
earliest until next time
thank you
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified click here